well I thank you Nick and welcome
everybody to today's meeting of the
cabinet quite an unusual meeting as a
first for me certainly to chair amazing
and I'm so much gonna call just one or
two little hiccups and you have managed
the technology as well as a business
sort of meeting and so can I thank
everybody for joining us and including
those who are watching on the livestream
I can also take this opportunity to wish
everyone a happy some georgia's day
today and also to our Muslim counselors
and residents are happy Ramadan which
begins tomorrow if members have
technical difficulties during the
meeting can they please contact the
Democratic services officer on Cole who
will attempt to assist you today's
democratic services officer is at
Charlotte's and her number is five
double seven one nine three also be at
the top of the chat thread for members
if you need it those of you watching via
the council's YouTube stream please
follow the instructions below the videos
below the video if there are any issues
with the live feed I would ask
participants when you are not speaking
please mute your microphone this
minimizes background noise and will help
everyone in listening to proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak to gain my permission to speak
please very briefly indicate on the chat
to the right side of the screen and I
will then make a note and go back to you
once the person speaking has finished
obviously we're all getting used to
these arrangements but please know that
we will be following protocol in which
other members of the council usually
only speak once on each item and I've
probably been a bit flexible in that
when we've been meeting in person I
think today we're going to have to stick
to the rules because otherwise it's
going to get too confusing in terms of
the environment for the meeting with
everyone please now please ensure that
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and they're not used to make or receive
phone calls while the meetings in
progress please also refrain from
checking emails or conducting other
business and ensure that you're in a
quiet room free from distractions for
the duration of the meeting this meeting
is being live-streamed for members of
the public and can also be recorded and
when we subsequently broadcast on the
Internet
please can I ask members of the cabinet
to confirm that they're present in the
meeting when I read out your name I will
ask for the attendance of those
counselors are participating in order to
speak under counsel procedure all 20.1
separately first of all counselor Wade
present Thank You counselor Albin here
counselor Duckworth here and counselor
eights here okay so we're all here the
following members have asked to speak
under counsel procedural 20.1 so when I
say your name can you please confirm
your present intimating an item for
counselor Campbell I'll see counsel
Campbell's just joined us perhaps you'll
confirm that he's here well I tried
about five or six times to actually get
on to the stream and I was the only
person there now you seem to have all
off better than this 24 of you have
appeared but how how what a mind
or better late than never cast okay I'm
here now with a coterie of questions
about agenda okay okay okay we'll come
back up come back to in due course
counselor Bailey hi I'm here Thank You
councillor Hart
yes I'm here okay and then the lights on
five its councillor Bailey again and
their counselor pew yes I'm here oh and
cancel the game yes I'm here thank you
are there any other counselors present
that wish to speak under council
procedural rule 20.1 hello Bob Bayside
I'd like to speak under is it item for
the destination management plan please
okay thank you thank you so we move into
the formal phase than a meeting there
are no apologies for absence because
we're all here declarations of interest
does anyone have an interest to declare
in the items of business on the agenda
this evening
receiving any indications that people
wish to raise any declarations of
interest minutes of the previous meeting
to improve the summary of
recommendations and decisions to the
cabinet meeting held on the 12th of
March 2020 copy which is attached to the
agenda bank I'll propose the minutes can
have a seconder please second it
seconded by Councillor Yeates
and if I hear any objection now I'll
take those as approved no objections for
those minutes are approved so we move on
to item 4 which is the Atlantic
destination management framework and I
shall bring in councillor Duckworth the
destination management framework sets
Act shared key priorities for
strengthening and growing the visitor
economy for the next five years the
framework focuses on key things that
will make the biggest difference to
growing fan its visitor economy and
making it more sustainable and builds on
the work Eve through the first
destination management plan which was
developed in 2012 13 the Tourism Service
commissioned leading travel consultants
B sale last autumn to develop the
framework which draws on views of local
stakeholders these views were gathered
through one-to-one meetings interviews
an interactive workshop with more than
50 people attending and via an online
survey Lusail also used recents research
both at the local level including volume
and value data the results of visitor
surveys carried out face to face and
perception research as well as national
research on holiday trends and coast
perceptions the priorities and actions
in the framework include making fanox
Town Center's more attractive to
visitors and providing more of the right
kind of accommodation then it also has
the benefits of bidding in see the
future high street fund the Ramsgate and
has been allocated at a deal opportunity
for Margate looking at year-round
experiences activities and facilities at
key sites along the coast including
reviewing the opportunity of
in the council's ownership and taking
advantage of the growth interest in
well-being experiences and outdoor
activities using strong themes to
develop a distinctive and authentic
welcome that encompasses that is to
experience at every moment
tourism team will support the private
sector to develop experiences via the
Internet experience project working with
visit Kent the destination management
framework is for all partners in the
destination and focuses on things that
can be realistically achieved by public
private and third sector parties working
together partnership working in
collaboration will be key to moving our
tourism industry forward after the K
vat19 crisis and for helping us to
retain the 319 million pounds that
tourism is worth for a local economy and
the seven 7950 jobs 20 percent of jobs
in Thanet it supports plus the local
services it supports and locals quality
of life I propose that the cabinet
recommends that thank District Council
members formally adopts the Fernet
destination management framework Thank
You councillor duckworth I'll second
that myself and then we'll hear I think
from first one is counselor Campbell yes
on page 9 of the agenda it states that
there was an interactive workshop who
from a translate Town Council attended
that interactive workshop referred to
pull the whole [ __ ] for that one okay
good evening everybody and yes two
representatives to email addresses were
sent to you for Ramsgate Town Council
and in addition to that town promoter
was invited and the Ramsgate v.i.c the
town program promoter actually attended
and the session there was a dedicated
invite where it went
you guys get Town Council then there was
a follow-up email and then there was the
survey was also sent okay
so no member in actual fact around had
to make out or attended the invitation
when that's not the case I'm just saying
but there was no elected member of genda
programs like Town Council I'll take
that up with the Terrell thank you
okay next question perhaps are going to
you Pablo
page 18 or page 8 questions can you just
speak once and then you ask the officer
to respond to you because we don't know
how long she's gonna go on do it it's
not I will page 18 of the agenda or page
8 of the plan it mentions the actions
that the third District Council tourism
team have to have to actually carry out
how many members are there on this
actual team that's one question on page
19 of the agenda or nine of the plan it
says to explore opportunities that Beach
have seemed Ramsgate will have been
banking on about this for some times
because there are no beach at at all in
Ramsgate
I'd like to know why that opportunity
has never been explored in the in the
future in the past I should say also is
there a dedicated officer for the plane
is there a dedicated budget for the
plane and can you ensure that there will
be six monthly reports back on the
effectiveness of the plane there we are
leader the other questions Thank You
councillor Carol I don't know if council
wants to come in or just refers right
back to Harvey I can do on the budget
there's no specific budget I understand
but it's more around using principles of
the plan to inform our thinking and
projects and also working with other
partners to deliver the outcomes on the
other questions I refer to caller
Harbach thank you just to confirm so the
the team that will be working on this
will be an led by Louise ask you who's
the head of service
myself and two members of the tourism
team and so we will be working on it
together
the idea of beach shots Ramsgate has
been talked about many a times quite
correctly by councillor Campbell and
which is one of the reasons why it's on
the plan to be explored because we've
listened to stakeholders and listen to
others and that's why it's on the plan
to be explored with your leisure with
regards to a dedicated lead and that
would be myself as the tourism manager
reporting to Louise asked us had a
service and I believe the recommendation
in the report is that we report back
annually and to cabinet and and that
Louise will be the SMT and city and lead
on on the project and I just also with
regards to the question regarding budget
even though the plan doesn't have a
dedicated budget we are a partner in the
visit Kent interring experience campaign
which and the third priority we were
hoping to leverage out and visit support
for stakeholders as part of that thank
you Bridge cannot speak to the leader
please well counselor Campbell again you
know this isn't a debate no no no but I
understand that mr. Bridger stated
there'll be an annual report I just like
to ask the count the cabinet weather
lady would consider that being six
monthly report back given given the
perilous conditions that will provide
after the corvid 19 pandemic well uh
well I'm also to use that I'll have a
discussion with the chief exec I've done
rather than make a commitment now I
think we should never discussion about
it yes leader actually I think that
Chitauri appropriate because there's a
capacity issue and a relevance issue to
the current situation we need to
consider that in that context thank you
okay councillor Bailey's your turn good
evening and this is for you have really
welcomed this destination management
plan I think it's really good especially
at this time after the Kovach 19
situation
and I just wanted to make an observation
I've worked for ten years as a volunteer
in the ebrill stairs information kiosk
one of the things that frustrates me
greatly is when visitors come to ask for
accommodation providers and there's all
we can basically do is to give them a
list of providers and they ring around
and until they find you know hip bingo
sort of thing find one with a vacancy I
just wondered as part of the destination
management plan whether or not there
could be some kind of planet-wide
accommodation website where
accommodation providers could give their
details and you know a bit like Expedia
sort of thing an opportunity funded by
fees from the hotels and providers
themselves and maybe advertising it's
just an idea because it is a very
frustrating thing when you're dealing
with with visitors thank you
Thank You councillor Bailey councillor
duddeck so many responses to that I mean
it seems like good idea if you got me
anything cooler that do you think you
could add to that is there anything
inlet in the pipeline
yeah we we used to have a system that
did allow that to do that so you would
show accommodation providers would show
their availability and but that was a
number of years ago now but because of
the increase on online travel agents and
white labeling so things like late room
Expedia the the choice of platforms that
the accommodation providers have got and
booking systems are quite varied and
visit England are developing a piece or
a piece of work and it has gone out and
we're working with accommodation
providers to get them up onto that
platform but it is a choice thing so it
depends on them they need to put in the
information for the consumer the visitor
to see and for you when you're working
right at the information kiosk and I
fully appreciate it's very very
frustrating but you're only as good as
the information you the provider wants
to give but there are systems in place
that they they will be able to use and
part of that is that you are will
accepts online bookings
so that your book a bill overseas and so
we've done some training with
accommodation providers and that will
still continue that's only been launched
in the last few months so yes things
will get better on that side I'm hoping
thank you okay thank you for that I've
got counselor Hart
good evening everyone um so some of this
might have been covered earlier um why
are we getting consultants in to tell us
what we should already know um and how
much did this cost and other counts was
actually going to get this done in in
what the report suggests and surely this
report could have been done in-house oh
that's it thank you rather than employer
consultant obviously that was you know
respond to that I'm again I refer that's
a porter again yet you're absolutely
right it could have been done in-house
there is we're only a small team so
there is a capacity issue with regards
to taking on large pieces of work
however the benefit that we have seen
like a lots of other major destinations
do see is by bringing outside
independent consultants in one we value
we get their experience of working with
lots of destinations but also
stakeholders get the opportunity to
speak freely ideas come forward that
might not come forward when you're
working with haces offices but offices
were very much involved in the process
the the consultants just helped develop
the plan and bring it together and it
wasn't a massive piece of work as you
can tell it wasn't a huge amount of
budget that was spent on it but it
helped with the facilitation which is
really important to pull out what
stakeholders and want to see happen in
the future and pull out what the
priorities are from a point of view of a
national level as well with regards to
their experience with where where
they've worked with other major
destinations not just in the UK but also
in Ireland and in other European and
European destination
thank you I think the chief executive
would lines coming yes thank you
leader yes I just wanted completely
endorse everything the Paula said in
respect of that last comment but also I
think the reason we brought in
consultants was the whole purpose was to
try and facilitate and obtain views from
staff and members in the council
unfortunately and I'm sure that's
completely valid reasons but
unfortunately very few members actually
attended the sessions that were provided
which which was a shame but that was
part of the rationale for bringing
somebody to independently facilitate
those discussions and I think it was
quite important we had someone with a
broader experience and some objectivity
to try and extract the benefit from
those sessions I also think we need to
mention that actually this report was
done before this current situation so we
do need to have a look at it now in
respect to of where we currently are and
what our recovery plans will be but it
will form part of that I think one of
the other questions accounts the heart
raised Paula and I've got to me I don't
know the answer to this off the top of
my head was the cost of the consultancy
so can you share that okay thank you for
that we can move on I think to council
Byford yeah Thank You chairman the
points in covered slightly by chief exec
I mean obviously this document has been
overtaken by events and the co bid 19
emergency and I think we're in situation
at the moment where we've got no idea
how long this emergency is going to go
on and what impacts there could be I
certainly think the longer it goes on
there could be a serious impact to our
tourism infrastructure and looking
further it could be that the general
public general populations behavior will
be impacted I think they might see
leisure patterns changed some by choice
and some by lack of cash and I just
wonder whether at the moment the
sensible thing would be to note this
rather than adopt it and then bring back
a revised report later on when things
have settled down and we know what the
future is likely to look like thank you
I don't think there's anything that so
set in stone it in the report that it's
that we can't kind of like accommodates
the future and it is mentioned in the
report Cove it 19 German in his answer
that Pooler I think the priorities of
the plan is about future growth I think
I don't disagree at all that the economy
is going to be massively impacted and I
hope that as we come out of this and I
said I think we would need to look at
this and but the priorities is still
about growth and I don't see that those
priorities are going to necessarily
change what we might need to do is maybe
to address areas can I just come in
there III would agree with that in
principle I do think we need to
understand it in the context of our
current situation but as I mentioned it
can form part of the recovery I think
the principles are there and I think
there that that's the important part
that we take from that document and some
of the direction setting and we may need
to adapt some of it slightly but I would
agree I think it's still important and
it's important message to say that we
are forward-looking so I think we should
be adopting it or I think rather members
should be considering adopting it rather
than holding it and bring it back
because I think that gives a positive
message to the to all of our
stakeholders that actually we are we do
have an eye on the future as well as the
current situation thank you I mean I I
agree with that I think we should have
done
or me clearly we are in a new situation
and we're going to have to do a lot of
thinking about what the future looks
like over the coming weeks and months
but I think we are ready to do this I've
seen any other member indicate that they
want to speak on this item from the
cabinet so unless anybody does want to
say anything further the recommendation
has been moved that some cats that
cabinet formula not the destination
management framework unless I hear any
objection now I'll take that as approved
and I'm not hearing any objection so
that is approved so we move on to item 5
which is the planet local claim
inspectors report regulation 25 26 and
that is my item so I will introduce it
we're now at the final stages of the
work towards the adoption of a new local
plan for Fannett the plan is part of the
council's policy framework and is
therefore required to be adopted by a
meeting of the full council which is
currently scheduled for the 9th of July
there will also be an opportunity for
the final draft plan to be discussed at
the overview and scrutiny panel on the
26th of May the draft Fayette local plan
was submitted for independent
examination in October 2018 examination
hearings commenced on the 2nd of April
2019 and finished on the 18th of july
2019
following the examination the planning
inspector recommended a number of
modifications to the draft plan these
proposed modifications were subject to a
public consultation inspectors have now
considered the representations major
into consultation and have submitted
their report to the council which is
attached to this report where annex 1
the inspector is required to make a
judgement about the soundness of the
draft plan the overall conclusion of the
inspectors report is that the draft plan
is sound subject to the adoption of the
modifications recommended within their
report a summary of the modifications is
attached to annex 2 the final draft of
the local plan incorporating inspectors
recommended modifications is attached to
this report annex 3 this report
recommends the modified local plan be
recommended to full council for adoption
the report also recommends that the
landscape characteris
be adopted as a supplementary planning
document and I move the recommendations
in the report do I have a seconder
please the our second chair
seconded by Councillor Albin and we've
got some speakers and the first speaker
is councillor Bailey hi again
well I'm really pleased that we're
almost got to the point where we're
going to drop this local plan because I
know it's been taken a long time and
obviously it gives greater control and
stability over the future of thermit and
I also recognize all the hard work and
the has gone into producing it I just
wanted to ask one question it really
concerns the extent of council powers
are supposed to do with SB 20 how
stringent will Mitchell's be in holding
developers to account in building 30% of
social housing when there seems to be a
in in bill get out clause when it says
that the requirement will be reduced if
meeting them would demonstrably make the
proposed developments unviable I just
wondered house has what strong powers
the council has to hold developers to
their their agreements yeah well
obviously the council has to make a
judgment on the viability which is
you're no doubt aware it can be quite a
complex process I don't know where that
either mr. Porter on mr. barrel would
like to come in and speak on that you've
said viability he does have to be taken
into account and government guidance is
quite clear that we shouldn't be
imposing costs which actually prevent
development so we had a viability study
carried out as part of the local
planning process and that indicated that
the level of affordable housing that
we're seeking should be generally
achievable but not necessarily on all
sites because clearly each site is
different and won't have its own its own
costs so it's just something that has to
be taken into account at the planning
application
stage and I assume mr. Bell that this
could be severely impacted by any
significant change in the property
market which arises from the current
situation because we're really moving
into the unknown they're only that's
quite right and as you move east across
King the viability and development
science does become less and clearly the
current situation will not help with
that it will certainly make things more
difficult
okay thank you thank you for your
question counselor Bailey um councillor
Pugh yes thank you yeah my question is
centered on the planning specs that came
back and said that the overall housing
numbers that we've concluded in the plan
can actually be reduced
I think I believe about 1300 but my
question really centers on the original
plan that was rejected in 2018 had a lot
of housing allocated for the Madison
Airport site which in this plan was then
reallocated around I know in Manston
Village they saw an increase of about
five hundred units on a plot of land and
the same in minster land to the west of
Tarheel street the allocation went out
from 150 to 250 and particularly in West
Gate umber tintin they saw quite a huge
increase in the housing numbers
designated to those areas so I suppose
my question is although the plan
inspector is said that housing delivery
can be slowed over the first five years
to account for this decrease of 1300
units is there a possibility that
actually that decrease could then be put
back into these areas that saw the large
increase to account for some of the
Manson Airport allocation okay that's
what a technical once I think I'm going
to pass thanks to mr. Verrill as well
thank you just clarify firstly the
inspectors didn't actually reduce the
overall number what they did was to
reduce the number in the first five
years but to retain the total for the
plan period so there's not actually a
reduction in housing
as overall it's simply the in the first
five years they've reduced it to
recognize market and infrastructure
constraints and then they've sort of
pushed that reduction out to the later
years so there's no actual reduction so
we are still we still have to find the
full amount once the airport allocation
was removed okay sorry so I I must have
misread it because I mean I've misread
it when the news broke and it says that
the district is required to deliver
seventeen thousand one hundred and forty
homes but the council has identified the
potential for eighteen thousand four
hundred and fifty seven homes so does
that mean that we won't we won't now be
able to reduce that at all but because
of past delivery issues we have to have
what's called a 20 percent delivery
buffer so you have to add 20 percent on
top of the seventeen thousand one
hundred and forty so that the seventeen
thousand one hundred forty is regarded
as a minimum figure it's not a target in
itself okay thank you all right thank
you thank you can't sleep you and the
other speaker is counselor going I know
that there's probably going to be a
debate about where the houses are going
to be situated doing eat that many and
are some of the sites too large but and
I think we've all got those those
questions but I think the priority at
the moment especially in this these done
certain times is to actually get this
plan through it's very very risky not to
have the plan and in fact it could be
yet with Kovac 19 and everything it
could in fact we don't know what's going
to happen with the building market
effect it could be even more of a risk
so I think although we've probably all
got questions and we're all not sure and
some bits we don't
like I think at the moment it has to go
through thank you thank you thank you
cancel game I think that's very helpful
and certainly my opinion that we need to
move forward with what we've got now and
obviously there's been a long process
over many years in the fact in which
people have argued about what should be
in the plane but we are under scrutiny
we're under scrutiny from the Secretary
of State we're under pressure in terms
of the fact that some five your housing
supply which we need to establish and
for all now that it's imperative that
the council moves on and adopts the
document it's got in front of us but
there will be an opportunity for
scrutiny to bring forward comments and
for comments to be made at full council
where we can have these discussions but
I think the message has got to be it's
time we get on with it and I'm very
grateful for your for your thoughtful
thank you okay so this any member of I
got a councillor are I've got was
requesting to speak under all 20.1
cancer are are you there
doesn't seem so does it its chairman
she's only just met they request now so
maybe she's trying to join in ah well
there isn't really a lot of
opportunities who to hold that
proceedings unless any of any other
cabinet members got anything to say at
this point I can't see neither would you
may I ask the question okay oh it's I
may have missed this in the noble plan
but as we know the neighborhood plans
that have to be an integral component of
the local plan and I just wondered what
the current situation is and with the
district's neighborhood plans thank you
I'm sure mr. Verrill can give you an
update on that because we in regularly
discs thank you
yeah there are a full neighborhood plans
that's proceeding in there of different
stages Broadstairs is the most advanced
there's an examination going on at
present the Burton made the plan and the
Westgate neighborhood plan or a draft
stage and I think there's a Ramsgate
plan also be developed which is slightly
behind the birch into new Westgate plans
so yes the two things sit alongside each
other as part of the development plan
okay thank you okay well councillor
Pooh's wants to ask another question
I don't think councillor Aras going to
join us I suspect she thinks the
meetings at 7 o'clock a council of pure
watch will exercise my discretion and
later ask another question Thank You
council Everett I was just being cheeky
if we were waiting for counts down but
my is a smaller question shorter
question but and I noticed the plan
Inspectorate in their decision gave
reference to Mastan Airport and the need
for a new policy and procedure that
we're currently waiting for the decision
on the DCO how will that impact on the
new policy and if there will be one
and do we have any kind of idea of time
scales well I know that we're going to
move straight into a review of the plan
and that's one of the inspectors
recommendations and that will be based
on in part on the decision that we get
on the DCO assuming we get a decision
because I'm not sure but that certain in
the current crisis I've been with mr.
Farrell wants to add anything to that I
know that I think I can add to that
later thank you okay thank you
right okay well I don't think counsel
and if somebody tells me otherwise I
don't think a stars on the now it's not
on there now no okay okay so if there
are no other cabinet members who wish to
speak on this Ison we've recommended
recommendations have been moved and
seconded that we adopt the same Local
Plan subject to the modification set out
in the inspection support and adopt the
landscape character assessment as a
supplementary planning document so
unless I hear any objection I will take
these as being recommended to Council
I'm not hearing any objection so that is
agreed and that concludes the business
for tonight's meeting
so I declare this meeting closed at 1738
thank you very much for everyone who
participated and to those of you
watching from home and the live stream
of this meeting will now end good
evening